bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qu'on va rendre obligatoire au
non vaccinés contre la bêtise
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du problème de la prédation sur
nos entreprises françaises bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ces caches bercy en a
identifié un peu plus de 500 depuis un
an et demi les alertes concernant les
menaces de prédation sur des entreprises
françaises se multiplient alors quelles
sont concrètement les entreprises
menacées comment contrer ses prédations
étrangères on va en parler dans cette
émission et pour cela nous recevrons en
deuxième partie frédéric pierucci ancien
cadre dirigeant d'alstom aujourd'hui à
la tête elle dit car ayant une société
de conseil le 6 et le service de
l'information à stratégique et de la
sécurité économique a été créé en 2016
il est rattaché à bercy et il garde un
oeil sur les entreprises stratégiques
françaises et les menaces de prédation
qu'elles peuvent subir c'est son patron
qui a récemment agité les chiffons
rouges voyait pourquoi avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine d'assas
[Musique]
c'est une alerte lancée il ya quelques
semaines par bercy les entreprises
françaises stratégiques pourraient être
menacés d'une prédation en provenance de
l'étranger
le chef du service de l'information
stratégique et de la sécurité économique
à bercy geoffrey célestin urbain l'a
affirmé il ya quelques semaines alors
que la france et le monde entier sont
plongés dans l'une des plus fortes
crises économiques de l'histoire
certains pays grandes puissances
économiques pouvant parfois même être
des alliés se sont relevés plus vite que
la france du coc vide ce qui les place
dans une position avantageuse pour aller
racheter des fleurons stratégiques chez
nous le service de l'information
stratégique et de la sécurité économique
déclare son niveau de vigilance je cite
très très élevé et il y a des exemples
récents concret en début d'année bruno
le maire avait dû mettre son veto face à
une menace de rachat de carrefour par
l'entreprise québécoise couche tard
autre exemple le gouvernement s'était
opposé au rachat de photos nice une pme
bordelaise spécialisée dans les
instruments de vision nocturne par
l'américain télé d'ein bref bercy veille
au grain pour éviter toute perte qui
mettrait à mal les forces économiques du
pays et garde un oeil en particulier sur
4000 entreprises de sa base industrielle
et technologique de défense
en 2020 le ministère de l'économie a
identifié 270 menace de prédation sur
des entreprises stratégiques françaises
et le rythme aurait augmenté puisque
très récemment
geoffrey série saint urbain affirmé
recevoir une alerte de sécurité
économique par jour olivier le pays
entre dans une deuxième vague de
pressions économiques étrangères très
fortes déclarations du patron du cissé
devant les sénateurs qu'est ce qui fait
selon vous que ça arrive maintenant
parce que c'est très simple c'est c'est
à l'occasion de deux crises économiques
et quand vous avez un pays qui est
affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
plus affaibli que les autres parce que
incapable de se réformer ou autre eh
bien vous avez vous avez à ce moment là
évidemment un état de faiblesse générale
qui fait que ça intéresse les prédateurs
parce qu'ils savent que vous ne pourrez
pas vous défendre donc
c'est normal que ça arrive maintenant
regardez d'ailleurs ça a même été à un
moment la prédation a été organisées
quasiment par par l'europe vis-à-vis de
la grèce
quand la grèce a été en faillite et bien
la grèce a vendu ses bijoux de famille
ces entreprises son port ses aéroports
experts a à des groupes étrangers parce
que parce qu' il fallait que l'allemagne
se rembourse de de ce qu'elle de ce
qu'elle versait et les européens se
rembourse aussi de ce qu'ils versaient
donc quand on a un pays qui qui est dans
une dans une position économique très
faible et bien évidemment les prédateurs
s'y intéressent comme dans la nature en
général on vont c'est l'animal blessé
qui qui est mangée en premier donc ça
n'a rien d'étonnant
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec fédérer frédéric pierucci bonjour
monsieur vous êtes un ancien cadre
dirigeant à d'alstom vous dirigez
aujourd'hui icarian une société de
conseil vous êtes aussi membre fondateur
de l'observatoire de l'intelligence
économique français et puis enfin vous
êtes l'auteur du livre le piège
américain aux éditions jc lattès merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci
alors frédéric il ya pierucci face à la
hausse des menaces de prédation sur les
entreprises françaises on l'a vu bercy
est sur le pied de guerre mais
concrètement qui attaquent nos
entreprises et comment se matérialise
ces menaces alors déjà effectivement la
crise accélère ce processus mais c'est
un processus qui avec ses qui a commencé
depuis très très longtemps et la
prédation des entreprises françaises par
des entités étrangères n'est pas
nouvelle
les ce qui est un peu nouveau c'est bien
évidemment que sex toute période de
crise accélère ses process et processus
mais aussi que la façon dont les
processus se met en place son esprit
juste un peu non conventionnelles c'est
à dire que il ya le darwinisme classique
et que économique et qui est en place
depuis très très longtemps les gros
mangent les petits affaibli mais là on
se trouve devant un nouveau type de
risque que vous fonds auxquels font face
les entreprises s'étaient sont des
risques non classique je m'explique non
classique plus de plusieurs natures
le droit est maintenant utilisée par les
états pour aider les entraîneurs
d'entreprise notamment à ceux affaiblir
d'autres entreprises étrangères
donc là qui attaque qui tout le monde
attaque tout le monde actuellement nous
il n'y a pas de régulation mondiale sur
sur sur ces sujets là et chacun y va de
sa propre lois extraterritoriales pour
comment pour attaquer des entreprises
étrangères
donc ça nous l'avons déjà vécu en france
avec 14 milliards de dollars payés par
les entreprises françaises au trésor
américain pour enfreinte l oua
extraterritoriale américaine ce qui
affaiblit considérablement les
entreprises pour voir régulièrement
c'est que lorsqu'il ya une attaque de ce
type là sur saône une entreprise
qu'elles soient françaises ou allemandes
etc
derrière souvent il ya une hydre obéit à
une opération de rachat donc c'est ce
sont des opérations de rachat qui se
prépare sur sur le long terme qui ont
été au début initiés on va dire par par
les états unis avec comme cible
principale des entreprises européennes
mais qui maintenant vont ce type de
pratiques vont être étendus à d'autres
pays on pense notamment à la chine qui
prépare ses doigts extraterritoriale et
à l'europe qui commencèrent à réagir
aussi donc ce risque non
conventionnelles va poser beaucoup de
problèmes à toutes les entreprises
françaises notamment est beaucoup plus
difficile à matérialiser est anticipé
par nos dirigeants qui ne sont pas
forcément formés sur ce type de
nouvelles de nouvelles attaques olivier
à ce niveau d' alerte je rappelle que le
patron a dû cissé évoqué plus de 500
alerte en un an et demi est ce qu'on
peut parler de guerre il ya une claire
écoles
mix assez évident est menée par les
états unis avec ce problème de
d'extraterritorialité du du dollar on
l'a vu depuis un bon moment
qu est ce qu ils font ils font un tiers
du du pib mondial donc il est évident
que ils peuvent vous menacez et vous
coller des amendes en vous disant de
toute façon si vous les payez pas eh
bien vous êtes interdit de travailler
soit en dollars soit sur la zone etats
unis et donc n'importe quelle entreprise
mondiale va céder à ce chantage parce
que l a pas les moyens de se passer du
marché américain et de se passer de deux
traités en dollars donc vous avez eu ça
par exemple sur aussi tout le système
bancaire suisse mais aussi la deutsche
bank mais aussi la société générale la
bnp qui ont été taxés d'amande et où on
leur a dit c'est simple soit vous payez
soit vous ne travaillez plus aux états
unis et vous ne travaillez plus en
dollars donc évidemment si vous voulez
sous cette menace tout le monde
s'exécute et comme il n'y a pas de de
réciprocité réellement européennes en
tout cas pour l'instant où on aurait
très bien pu dire bah écoute et
messieurs c'est très simple vous
travaillez plus sur les marchés
européens non plus si si vous continuez
comme ça il n'y a pas eu cette cette
unité il n'y a pas eu cette défense là
donc l'europe encore une fois n'a pas
servi à grand chose et est donc on s'est
laissé ponctionné par l'état américain
ce qu'il arrange bien d'ailleurs il se
fait quelques points de pipe comme ça
tous les ans c'est pas mal c'est une
bonne méthode
frédéric pierru si vous êtes d'accord
avec ça il n'y a pas d'unité pas de
défense alors c'est un peu le chacun
pour soi dieu pour tous actuellement
dans cette guerre économique et qui est
vraiment sans pitié avec comme on l'a
dit des moyens de guerre économique non
non conventionnelles alors il ya des
embryons de défense qui
son sont en train d'être mis en place
niveau 2 d'étape des états la france a
commencé à réagir à cet extra
territorialité américaine avec
l'instauration sur la partie antique
évolution de la loi sapin 2 qui permet
aux entreprises françaises
maintenant on fait de régler un peu
leurs problèmes en france donc on a un
début un début de réponse mais c'est
surtout une arme défensive et surtout il
n'y a pas de de vraiment de réponse
européenne sur ces sujets là parce que
il ya eu aussi une grosse concurrence
entre européens et il ya aussi des
prédations versé à minignan
intereuropéennes et chaque pays en
europe à sa propre politique vis-à-vis
des etats-unis et vis-à-vis de la chine
vis-à-vis de la russie
donc c'est un peu chacun pour soi dieu
pour tous alors il ya certaines
initiatives au niveau européen parce que
un des moyens aussi de capter des
informations c'est bien évident de régir
le droit du numérique et là on voit la
guerre entre les états unis et l'europe
et maintenant avec la chine sur la
captation de des données donc là là là
l'europe réagit un peu avec sur la
captation des données en tous les cas
personnels avec le verger et avec la
dernière décision de la cour de justice
européenne sur ce qu'on appelle la
région m ce qui est interdit dans mon
transfert des données personnelles de
l'europe vers les états unis
mais tout cela est encore très
embryonnaire et ne constitue pas une
vraie politique industrielle
ce que nous aurions besoin déjà avant de
pouvoir réagir c'est déjà de définir
quelle est notre politique industrielle
qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'appelle-t-on une
entreprise stratégique comment la
préserver quels sont les secteurs sur
lesquels il faut il faut s'orienter pour
l'instant on est plutôt dans le dans
leur est actif via ces attaques qui
viennent un peu de toutes parts dans
quel secteur
concrètement évoluent les entreprises
les plus menacés ce qu'on est capable de
te faire un point sur les secteurs en
fait au début les secteurs les plus
menacés et et les secteurs
traditionnellement stratégique on va
dire la production d'électricité le
pétrole les télécoms etc
mais maintenant ce qu'on voit c'est que
c'est tout azimut on s'est bien rendu
compte avec la crise et que vides que
une fabrication de masques peut-être
aussi stratégique
donc ce qu'il va être important de
définir au niveau de l'état c'est de
choisir nos dépendances
on ne peut pas vivre en autarcie bien
évidemment mais l'important est de
choisir les dépendances et de trouver si
on a des failles dans le système de
trouver des fournisseurs multiples pour
ne pas se retrouver dans des situations
de monopole ou de manque comme nous
l'avons été dans le récepteur de du
masque donc l'agriculture va être un
élément majeur
en fait il faut considérer sur chaque
pan de l'industrie
les secteurs les plus stratégiques l
aider des entreprises les plus
stratégiques et cette analyse là n'est
pas fait pour l'instant on n'est plus
dans la réaction avec effectivement là
ce que ce qu'a dit je ferai ce destin
humain 10,6 et il protège les
entreprises dès que dès qu'il peut y
avoir d'aidé des alertes mais on a
besoin surtout une politique
industrielle est actuellement et depuis
qu'on a plus de mystère de l'industrie
en france on a plus politique
industrielle en france
c'est ça le louvre le gros problème et
personne ne va faire cet étudiant du
ciel ce n'est pas l'europe qui va faire
la politique industrielle de la france
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
en rien dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces cas si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine les
menaces de prédation sur les entreprises
françaises et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec frédéric pierucci ancien
cadre dirigeant d'alstom est aujourd'hui
à la tête dit car ayant une société de
conseil olivier juste avant la pub
monsieur pierre ruetschi évoqué un
problème c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
politique industrielle d'accord avec ça
oui totalement
2 mais ça fait longtemps c'est pas ça
date pas de diers et puis il ya aussi un
double langage du politique qui dit je
protège mes par exemple je mets les
barrages en vente et donc je rappelle
quand même que les barrages c'est
essentiellement stratégique donc et puis
vous avez payé les pots cassés sur sûr
album et donc sur les turbines des
centrales nucléaires qui aujourd'hui
nous appartiennent plus donc il ya ceux
il ya quand même ce cette espèce de de
langage très peut-être très volontariste
ces derniers temps mais ça n'empêche que
au final
aujourd'hui on se laisse quand même
faire beaucoup
alors que la réciproque n'est pas vraie
c'est à dire que quand vous essayez de
d'acheter une entreprise chinois je vous
souhaite bien du plaisir ça se fait pas
comme ça il ya des règles ils se
défendent donc il s'agit pas de vivre en
autarcie mais il s'agit de d'essayer de
1 d'être autonome plus autonomes en tout
cas qu'on ne l'est aujourd'hui
et puis deux de se défendre c'est à dire
d'installer des réellement des pare feu
qui qui fasse que l'on puisse dire non
quelle qu'en soit la raison qu'on puisse
dire non à un achat de d'entreprises
étrangères comme le font les autres pays
et tant que ea le protégeons leur leur
industrie et que nous on la protégera
pas eh bien on sera les dindons de la
farce alors pourtant quand on prend par
exemple la sphère photonis bercy avait
mis son veto à une tentative de rachat
par un groupe américain
ça signifie tout de même que la
politique de défense de la france
fonctionne un petit peu con à certains
outils pour se défendre dans la sphère
photonis la dta d'abord donner son
accord avant que les conditions ne
soient pas acceptable par appart les
dîners que teledyne y renonce donc il ya
eu plusieurs affaires de plusieurs
étapes de ping pong entre eux entre
l'état
et été les dignes et le fond ardien
qu'ils détenaient photo nice
donc il faut pas oublier quand même que
l'état avait donné son accord à un
moment donc on a eu le même problème que
sur alstom avec l'affairé y sommes c'est
l'état donné son accord en mettant des
mesures un peu cosmétique deux en dix
ans le touchant la propriétaire actuelle
on va la garder en france si jamais
gagné un problème on pourra nos armées
dans le cas de sony pourront garder la
propriété intellectuelle et dans lequel
alstom edf faudra regarder la vie
intellectuelle des turbines etc
mais tout ça c'est un peu une vie de
l'esprit de gens qui n'ont pas vécu de
devenir un classique une une entreprise
qui n'ont pas vécu ce que c'est que de
construire une turbine que deux c'est de
protéger la propriété d'une entreprise
donc tous ces mesures un peu cosmétique
ne règle pas le ne règle pas le problème
de fond qui les problèmes de fond c'est
que lorsque des entreprises comme sa
stratégie qui se font acheter je vous
prendre le cas d'el d'alstom
quelques mois après le rachat par
general electric d'alstom jean eric a
menacé edf d'arrêter de fournir des
pièces de rechange pour les centrales
nucléaires françaises
donc vous imaginez que le pouvoir que
vous donnez une entreprise étrangère sur
l'économie d'un pays
arrêter de fournir des pièces de
rechange pour les centrales nucléaires
françaises c'est mettre le pays dans le
noir sont 15 % d'électricité en france
est produite par du départ du nucléaire
donc vous donner des moyens à des
entreprises étrangères et donc à des
gouvernements étrangers parce que des
entreprises telles que des briques sont
extrêmement proches des pouvoirs
américains leur donner des moyens de
pression absolument colle aux colossaux
sur sur l'économie d'un pays
vous avez voulu réagir oui mais c'est
c'est ce que je vais dire c'est à dire
que y'a ce double langage qui est qui
peut se montrer très ferme mais qui qui
se se couche bien souvent devant les
états unis parce que je vous dis le les
américains ont ce pouvoir là grâce au
dollar qui est la monnaie internationale
même si beaucoup se dé dollar is en ce
moment mais on en est très très loin du
compte et ils ont
7cette extraterritorialité du dollar qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui se permettre
n'importe quoi et donc comme en plus en
europe
nous avons des gouvernants qui sont
quand même très avec un penchant très
atlantiste on va dire pour pas dire
autre chose
eh bien on se couche bien souvent alors
là en effet ça a fait un tel tollé que
ils ont fini par par intervenir mais
comme le dit monsieur karoutchi
au départ il avait donné quand même leur
accorde donc ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire c'est que il laisse partir
quand même des fleurons sont sans se
poser de questions parce que aussi et il
l'a dit aussi ils ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'une entreprise tous les gens
qui sont aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'économie ne savent pas ce que c'est
qu'une entreprise d'ici ont jamais mis
les pieds
ils sont ils sont sortis de l'ena ils
sont allés directement dans le ministère
et aujourd'hui ils n'ont aucune idée de
ce qu'est une entreprise donc ne leur
demandez pas à défendre quelque chose
qui ne connaissent pas ça peut pas
marcher
frédéric pierru shekels quels outils
faudrait-il mettre en place pour rendre
nos entreprises moins vulnérables le
problème ne sont pas les outils les lois
nous les avons les outils nous les avons
nous nous avons besoin c'est une vraie
politique industrielle et d'une vraie
volonté politique pour passer des
paroles aux actes
et ça c'est vraiment le gros saut six
mois très franchement les etats-unis
jouent leur jeu on ne faut pas leur en
vouloir
ce sont les ils ont une puissance
militaire qui fait qu'ils puissent qui
peuvent essayer d'imposer leurs droits
au reste du monde
ils jouent leur carte les chinois demain
vont jouer leur carte les russes vont
jouer leur carte le problème ne venait
pas chez les états unis les chinois ou
les lions ne sais pas mais c'est chez
nous il faut régler le problème chez
nous il faut qu'on ait des personnes qui
aient le courage de prendre des
décisions politiques et industrielles
fortes dans un moment où on va dans une
guerre économique encore plus exacerbée
avec
la période de la période puisqu'au vide
est une des choses qu'il faudrait déjà
faire c'est créer les moyens financiers
de pouvoir de nos ambitions
pour l'instant il nous n'avons pas de
fonds souverain français qui peut
investir dans des entreprises
stratégiques
donc si vous laissez le marché classique
du private equity se charger de votre
politique industrielle et de notamment
de votre politique de souveraineté
industrielle vous avez un problème parce
que ces fonds ces fonds n'ont pas
forcément envie d'aller investir dans
des dents des industries stratégiques et
là c'est là où l'état pourrait faire
quelque chose en créant un fonds
souverain qui est aurait pour but comme
bon nombre d'autres pays 2 justement
préserver cette épique et de regarder
surtout le long terme et ne pas le nom
pas le court terme politique ne pas
regarder la prochaine la prochaine
élection là lorsqu'on parle de
l'industrie souveraine on parle là on
parle de nucléaire on parle de télécoms
on parle du numérique il faudra un grand
plan du numérique en france qu'on a
réussi à le faire dans les années
soixante dix avec le nucléaire où nous
avions aussi qu'un an de retard par
rapport à de grands pays nous avons eu
les ambitions et nous avons mis les
moyens en face pour créer les conditions
de notre indépendance énergétique en
france il faudrait faire la même chose
maintenant sur sur le numérique qui est
la plus grosse bataille à venir
là il faut juste du courage politique
olivier vous êtes d'accord la création
d'un fonds souverain pour investir dans
nos entreprises c'est une bonne idée
oui sauf que c'est beaucoup plus facile
de créer un fond souverain quand on a
des sous quand on en a pas or le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
qu'on est en pleine crise
qui a pas de soussous sauf pour aller
jouer sur sur quelques marchés à haute
volatilité et qu' on est en train de
s'endetter d'une façon ahurissante et
que
las je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
moment avec la bulle qui a eu d'aller
faire ses emplettes sur les marchés
financiers donc le problème il est là
c'est si vous voulez c'est que oui en
effet il aurait fallu le faire mais il
aurait fallu le faire il ya déjà un bon
moment de créer un fond souverain quand
on avait des sous aujourd'hui on en a
pas et donc voilà donc on est on est à
la merci on est à la merci aujourd'hui
que je vous dis comme comme la grèce en
2012 comme quand on est faible quand on
est à terre malheureusement c'est
difficile de se défendre
donc est évidemment tout le monde en
profite alors en effet c'est pas la
faute des américains c'est ça sera la
faute de tout le monde c'est tous les
pays qui sont concernés puisque tous les
pays ont été touchés par le copil oui
mais après il y en a certains disons
qu'ils ont géré différemment
nous ça fait ça fait 20 ans qu'on fait
absolument aucun effort ça fait 20 ans
qu'on n'a pas de femme m 30 ans qu'on
n'a pas de politique industrielle ça
fait 30 ans qu'on fait absolument tout
pour que les entreprises partent de chez
nous et maintenant il faudrait pas un
coup de baguette magique qu'elle
revienne mais elles n'ont pas du tout
envie de revenir pour la bonne et simple
raison que rien n'a changé
c'est même encore pire donc n'attendez
pas que les entreprises ferment
là où elles sont allées il ya vingt ans
pour revenir se précipiter en france
parce que tout d'un coup monsieur macro
aurait déclaré qu on était attractif
pour être attractif il faut changer les
choses faut changer les les les lillois
faut changer là là là le les règlements
les lois l'imposition et cetera qui ont
fait que les entreprises sont partis
elles sont bien partis pour une pour une
bonne raison si vous voulez parce que on
part pas comme ça on déménage pas à
l'autre bout du monde pour rien donc il
faut créer simplement le les choses de
changer les choses pour que les
entreprises est envie de revenir mais
aujourd'hui je doute qu'elle ait très
envie de revenir une dernière réaction
avant de se quitter
oui juste pour un petit bémol l'argent
nous l'avons si vous regardez les parm
des français sur sur le livret a et sur
les programmes d'assurance vie vous
rendez compte que il ya beaucoup
d'argent de départ n 2 français qui ne
sont pas utilisés pour l'économie
française
bessy alors lui donner un avantage
fiscaux est-ce que je peux juste vous
dire un petit a un petit truc l'état on
a besoin pour émettre ses obligations
l'état a besoin de l'edpams des français
ben oui mais en fait qu'est ce que font
les assurances vie qu'est ce que font
les grands banquiers et les grandes
assurances et bien elle finance l'état
et donc tout ce qui est tout ce qui
passe en achats d'obligations d'état ne
passera pas malheureusement en achat qui
serait je vous la corde beaucoup plus
intéressant mais ne passera pas en
achats d'actions de sociétés
potentiellement achetable par l'étranger
donc ça sert c'est magnifique c'est
juste mal fléché
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait mal
fléché et tant que nous n'avons pas
d'aidé des fonds de pension à
l'américaine ou à l anglaise
pour pouvoir investir sur sur le long
terme si vous en france pour l'instant
si vous essayez de faire des opérations
au dessus de 1 milliard il a prédit a
pratiquement pas de fond qui peut vous
accompagner donc vous retrouver avec des
fonds des fonds anglo-saxons à chaque
fois qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes les
mêmes visions une vision de
développement dans l'ordre puisque vous
donc c'est compliqué sa folie il faut le
réformer quand même il faut trouver un
moyen de d'avoir des fonds suffisamment
solide en france pour investir sur le
long terme dans le dans dans des
industries souveraine donc il ya
plusieurs pistes à exploiter ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est que demain nous
allons rien ne va se calmer tout va
s'accélérer et tout va aller beaucoup
plus vite
là on a beaucoup parlé des états unis
demain vous regardez ce qui est en train
de se passer en chine sont en train de
mettre en place des contrôles sanctions
aux sanctions américaines et le gros
gros risques pour les entreprises
européennes ça va être de s'être pris en
étau entre les sanctions américaines et
les contres sanctions et chinoise et
donc d'un côté ou d'un vous avez vous
faire taper dessus
d'un côté vous fermez le marché
américain de l'autre côté vous fermez
soit le marché chinois soit
l'approvisionnement que vous avez avec
vos usines en chine
donc il est urgent que l'europe
réagissent et surtout que la france
montre le chemin de l'europe sur le sur
ces sujets là parce que ce ne sont pas
les pays qui ont profité de la
délocalisation des entreprises
françaises vers l'europe de l'est qui
vont monter au créneau sur ces sujets là
les grands pays d'europe de l'est
slovaquie pologne etc ont énormément
bénéficié la destruction français dont
on parle beaucoup des décisions vers
l'asie mais on ne parle pas suffisamment
désertion des destinations vers l'europe
de l'est avec avec
avec l'élargissement de à 27 donc en
europe il n'y aura pas de consensus
entre entre les vingt-sept sur ces
sujets là et donc il faudra faudra que
nous commencions chez nous merci à
beaucoup frederico pierucci d'avoir
participé à cette émission je rappelle
que vous êtes un ancien cadre dirigeant
à d'alstom à la tête aujourd'hui 10 car
ayant une société de conseils que vous
êtes aussi est membre fondateur de
l'observatoire de l'intelligence
économique français et puis vous êtes
l'auteur du livre le piège américain à
découvrir aux éditions jc lattès merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant je vous laisse
avec le dernier mot d'olivier mais quand
on n'a pas de sous pas d'idées on se
fait dépouiller